[inaudible]
joining me today as a sociologist, a
physician, a professor at Yale University,
and author of the new book blueprint,
the evolutionary origins of a
good society. Nick Christakis,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me, dude.
I am happy to have you here sir.
But I'm depressed that I have to start
the show the way I sort of have to start
the show and I suspect, you know
how I have to start the show. Yeah.
So do you want to set it up for me?
Well, I mean we do just have to get
this out of, I know, I know. I mean,
I knew when the book was published.
I mean,
I've been working in the book for nine
years and I knew when it was published
that I would have to revisit those
events from 2015 which, you know,
we're just a challenging period of
my life. Um, thankfully in the past.
I'm really glad to have it behind
me. Yeah. But I recognize that.
So you tell whatever part
of it you want to tell.
Okay. So you are and were a
professor at Yale? Yes. This is,
this is in I think the fall
of 2015. Yes, it fall of 2015.
And your wife Erica, who's also a
professor, uh, childhood development.
She was an instructor but yes. Yes. So uh,
she basically wrote a piece that said it
was a defensive free speech and it was
sort of worked around the Halloween
costume idea that you know,
you should wear what you want but you can
try to be respectful of people but you
know, we shouldn't have some sort of
top down version where people, you know,
administrators or professors
are telling students what were,
you offered her a bit of a defense on
that and now I'll throw it in the clip.
Is that fair? Fair. Okay.
Let's throw it to the clip.
Don't need to bend down. I'm not bending.
What's your name? I don't want this.
I do not want you to take care. I
do not want, I do not respect you.
I'm going to hear that. I'm looking at
this rec in your face like I'm disgusting.
Okay. I am off and I'm sick
watching them argue with you.
I believe we've been standing on stage
literally for at least five to six hours
between you and Halloween,
which we last night to now,
we've been arguing with people who are
not willing to be listened to for a long
time. And all I see from
you is arrogance and ego.
I am sick looking at you. I am
disgusted watching, argue with you.
You are not listening.
You are disgusting.
I don't think you understand that.
And before I wasn't I before,
I was not angry per say,
I was disappointed.
Maybe I thought maybe there was
room for it before an apology.
You've clearly told us that you did not
plant. Offer an apology for your words.
You left the meeting last night
to go home and vent. Tweak.
Do not interrupt me to tweet from
your Twitter and then the filaments.
Twitter,
you showed no remorse.
You tried to let your wife leave that
conversation without having answered for
herself. That is disgusting. That is
sick. And now I wasn't angry before.
I was not angry before,
but now I am actually angry sir.
I really do not interrupt me.
I was not angry.
And now I want your job to be taken from
you. I don't want you to have this job.
I am disgusted knowing that you work
at Yale University where I will get my
degree. Well, I will look back and think
I have to argue with you. All right?
Don't Miss Sarah. Don't
do it. Don't do it. Third,
to not do it.
This is not the day you do not want to
play this game with meters out of thing.
You don't wanna play this game
with me. Okay? Understand that.
Look me in my face first of all
and understand that you are such a
disappointment to this university,
to your students, to yourself.
Do the things that you do claim to agree
with you are you want free dialogue.
You want free speech. This is how it
works. Someone speaks, you listen,
you're not cut them off. You did not
do these, these condescending gestures.
You do not smirk.
You look them in the face and you wait.
You wait until it's your turn.
Okay? So before we even dive into
that, the second we played the clip,
you let out a big exhale.
You just not was interested
in this anymore or it's
depressing to look back at.
Both are true. It's, you know, it's, um,
I was in the courtyard for two hours
and 15 minutes from four to six,
15 about an hour of footage has been
released of from five or six different
vantage points. You showed one clip that's
typically not the clip that's shown.
Um, so many people put
stuff online you can read,
you can piece together the
whole hour between five and six.
For the first hour that I
was out in the courtyard,
I listened quietly to the
students. Um, you know,
there's a lot of stuff that, that young
woman said that's just factually wrong.
Um,
she's alluding to an event that occurred
the night before at the Afro Afro
American Cultural House at Yale where
there was a huge event with hundreds of
students. Um, it had been
announced at the beginning that,
that we would have to leave that
event at the conclusion it was,
I can't remember the precise timing,
but I think it was
scheduled from six to eight.
My wife had to teach a class from seven
to nine, so she deals in the evening.
So she told her students she'd be
late and we'd stay from six to eight.
She did in fact speak
to the crowd. She, um,
had to leave to teach an eye.
We had a student in the hospital actually
that evening that I was responsible
for and that also was known.
So,
so when she said that we tried to
leave, that's not, that's false. Um,
you know,
I think that um,
many of the students were swept
up in a kind of a mob fervor.
I think they behave badly.
Um,
they should have known better.
I think they were trying to assert power.
If I had a tool when I was that age that
could get grownups into trouble. Right.
Uh, you know, probably I would just
get doing it nonstop, you know,
and they have found a tool often
are doing it. Yes. Yes. And so,
but so I think what distressed me is I
think at some point in the background of
that footage that one of the
administrators, actually the author,
what happened is,
is a man by the name of Howard.
I had moved from north western university
to Yale and had assumed a new position
there. And he had written an email. He
had written a memo while at Northwestern,
uh, admonishing students not
to wear a offensive costumes.
And I should say for the record that
many of the students that many of the
costumes that he or anyone else would find
offensive, I too would find offensive.
I wouldn't like these costumes.
I,
I'm well aware of the long
history of racism in our society.
I am well aware of the ways in which,
uh,
there's trafficking and certain cultural
tropes that put down other groups.
I reject. I am of, I've a
very pro immigrant policy.
I believe system. I, I think
that anyone can be an American.
I love the idea that we have open borders,
you know,
I mean I have all set of beliefs that
are around openness and welcoming or
lefty. Yeah. I am quite lot. I am
a lefty. I'm left of center plate.
I mean I have some conservative ideas,
some libertarian,
I think of myself as a classical liberal
and I think of myself as very pragmatic
and policymaking.
So I like,
I like markets to address
most allocation of goods,
but I also very concerned about market
failures and then I want government
intervention. Anyway, so,
um, so, uh, so that, anyway,
that man who was,
I then had moved to Yale and then he
took out of mothballs this email that he
had sent at Northwestern
five or 10 years earlier,
got a bunch of Yale administrators
to sign it and then send it off.
And in it he had links to approved and
non-approved costumes are very costumes
which were deemed to be
offensive in his email.
There were links to lots of
those ostensibly offensive
costumes and the students,
there had been a lot of
conversation at the time.
The New York Times had a big piece like
the previous month about the growing use
of Halloween costume advice at American
colleges. So it was in his, like guys,
this was the third,
his email was the third email that
had been sent out telling students,
giving them advice.
So in my wife's class,
many of the students in the class and
other students in the college where we,
the subpart of Yale that
we were responsible for
had told her that they felt
this was very infantilizing and they
didn't really need advice on what to wear.
And so my wife from a
developmental perspective wrote
a response to this email,
which itself had been, was signed
by 13 administrators. It, it didn't,
it was framed as guidance, but it
sort of had the color of law. And um,
so she wrote a response saying,
and her intellectual point was
not wear whatever you want.
Right.
Her intellectual point was,
do you students at Yale in your
twenties early twenties late teens,
early twenties really need older
adults to tell you what to wear,
provide you guidance. You should think
about that and decide whether you really,
and apparently many students
did want such guidance.
And so then I was then thereafter,
then all hell broke loose.
And I was in the court courtyard
and did the best I could. Yeah.
What do you make of the reason we chose
that cliff was because there is the
other more famous clip of, of the growth,
really liberating with, there were many,
many,
they were hired on you that,
that was the one that I
think we should note here.
And I think that's the
most of our little bubble.
I thought that one was interesting because
the angle was a little different and
you could see some of the other
kids and the, and the, you know,
the either tears or the look of horror,
all of these things when you
actually didn't do anything.
Well that's another whole
topic. I think that, um,
I mean many people have analyzed
those events and honestly, I don't,
I don't know if I have anything
to add to those analyses.
I think that the thing that
was very interesting to mean,
so, so one of the ideas that I've been
thinking about for a long time is this
tension between our individuality
and our group of shyness.
And we have evolved to, first of
all, it's a very interesting idea.
We've evolved to be individuals,
so we humans have unique identities.
So we have unique faces.
So you can look out at a sea of
people and can tell who's who.
And not only do we have the
ability to signal our uniqueness,
we use our faces for that,
but we have the cognitive apparatus
to detect that uniqueness.
So you can have a lot of
brainpower you haven't done,
you allocate to tell who's who.
So this ability to be individuals is
crucial for our ability to function in
groups.
It's very paradoxical because you need
the capacity to tell who's my offspring,
who's my friend? Who do I reciprocate?
Kindness to, who do I cooperate with?
Who's my enemy?
All of these things.
So all of these capacities
of individuality are
crucial to our collective
expression, our ability to
live together. But equally we,
um, we have this desire to
surrender ourselves to the group,
to do something called two d individually,
to form a part of a collectivity
to suppress our individual desires,
which also allows us to work together.
But the irony is when you'd get
too much of that, you get mobs,
you get panics, you get, you know, uh, uh,
all kinds of collective phenomena that
are destructive rather than constructive.
So when I was in the crowd, when I was in
that mob, I, I knew what was happening,
I could tell.
So one of the things I started doing
was as I started asking people,
what's your name? And I was trying to
connect to them person to person saying,
you know, hi, I'm Nicholas. Who are you?
So you're a person and I'm a person.
You're not a part of this, a mob. You're
a human being. And I am a human being.
And in fact,
the,
the one thing that happened that
that isn't as an intellectual idea,
that's part of this book that
I've been working on for 10 years.
But that also I made in the heat of the
moment is in the moment I said to the
students, I said that I
believe in our common humanity.
I believe that even though this person
and this person is superficially
different than me, nevertheless,
we can talk to each other.
We all have life experiences where
human beings and ended. And then if you,
if you don't believe that, if you don't
believe we have a common humanity,
which I see as a wonderful thing.
Yes, yes. Cause I'm an optimist.
I'm an optimist.
If you don't believe our common humanity,
why are you even trying to talk to
me and the students geared to, yeah,
they jeered it's on film.
They jeered and I honestly,
I think that's one of the most depressing
things that's happened that I've ever
seen actually said the yields students
in the 21st century would jeer at what I
regard to be a fundamental,
humane,
wonderful claim about human beings
is that we have a common humanity.
So, all right. So I know you don't
want to spend the whole time, but I do.
But I think a lot of this does segue to
your book for reasons that you just laid
out. So those trying to do that.
Yeah, I know you're a very clever,
you're tid bits. You can, I'll watch
what, I'm going to go back in there.
How did they get us there then?
Okay. Right on his back. Um,
but that look that you're talking
about when, when you say that,
like we have to be able to share a
common humanity. I've been there too.
I mean I face these mobs to do and what
I find is there's an actual look they
have in their heads where the individual
that you just spoke about is gone.
Um, did you think there was
anything, so I guess there's really,
in that case,
for the people that are watching this
that think that one day they are going to
go against the mob, is there any other
advice you would have for them on how to,
how to do it? Because that doesn't
always work. I mean, saying, I,
I've done that where I've said,
I'm standing right in front of you.
I'm listening to you.
My name's Dave and it doesn't work that
I think that, um, I,
I don't know. I, I don't know.
You know,
there's that,
there's that scene in Lord of the
rings where Aragorn rushes the gates,
you know, um, and have more door.
And I of course love those movies and uh,
you know,
I don't know if I would have,
I don't think,
I don't know if I would be
capable of such bravery, but, um,
intellectually I definitely am. That
is to say I'm not easily cowed. Um,
and I,
I have spent my life training myself
to think as clearly as I can to look at
evidence to collect evidence. I'm an if
scientist, I'm an empiricist. So, um,
so in the,
in the case of a mob,
I don't think I would yield to a mob
intellectually. Now, physically, you know,
if they're, if they're throwing bricks
at you as a different thing, but I think
you too often that threat is always there.
Even if they're not holding
a weapon that threads, right.
It's a dangerous situation. I
would agree. But mass, you know,
[inaudible] are always dangerous.
But my point is that I think that if you,
if you can keep your calm, you can think
clearly about what you're saying. Also,
if you've thought about these ideas
before in the cool of the day,
so it's not the heat of the moment said,
look, I really thought about these ideas.
This is not just a sudden heat of passion.
Like I've,
I've thought about this topic
or this point, whatever it is.
It doesn't have to be a political point.
It can be scientific point or something.
Then when you're pressed, you know, you
can say, you know, I'm listening to you.
Here's what I think. Okay. What
do you think? I think you can,
I think you can, you can, I won't
say you can win the battle of ideas,
but you can at least fight it. Well. Yeah.
What was the administration's
response after this older, well,
I think the administration
faced a difficult challenge
in deciding what to do.
Many people have commented on
what they did or didn't do.
I'm not sure I want to go into it. Um,
it took them quite awhile to come to,
to release any kind of public
statement in support of us. Um, so,
and you know,
many members of the administration,
junior members were actually involved in,
so in the crowd that day,
they were four, four administrators
actually, uh, who, um, you know,
who's others have since identified.
But um, you know, I think,
I don't think it was Yale at its best.
And um,
and I don't in the students were not
at their best and I was not at my best.
I did my best, but you know, I
think I could've done even better.
So as someone that then has lived
through it, where did this go wrong?
On college campuses because
for the past couple of years,
every time I see one of these stories
I think either, well, I used to think,
oh this, this is the end of it.
Now people will really get it.
Like I remember you're the one with you
from the other video clip that we didn't
show that people had seen. It was
like, this is so patently absurd.
Maybe this will finally
be the wake up call.
I've now come to believe that the wake
up call, these can come at anytime soon,
sadly. Um, but what, when
do you think as well,
I think this is a complicated
topic. I see. You know, this is not,
it was not my area of expertise.
I am a natural and social scientist.
I run a lab with computer scientists and
molecular biologists and sociologists
and evolutionary biologists,
and we work around the world who
do all kinds of stuff. So I was,
I have always been committed to liberal
principles including to free speech.
When, when I was at Harvard,
before I moved to Yale in 2013, uh,
my wife and I came to the defense of
minority students who were being, um,
having their right or speech
rights squelched on campus.
So I'm committed to these ideas, but it
wasn't the most central part of my life.
And I'm not an expert like John Height or,
or Greg Lukey off look Kiana far,
however, so, so I see
conflicting evidence.
I agree with you that there are a
lot of these salient cases which,
which they weren't before.
And Jonathan feels that they're still
rising and they have their own theories.
Jonathan and Greg about why I see
other evidence that looks at surveys of
college students and finds that they
are no more or less likely to want to
suppress the speech of others
than adults and older adults.
It's very tempting to silence people
who don't agree with, right? I mean,
everyone wants to do that,
but I don't,
I want to talk to them and persuade
them like it would be, it would be,
it's very tempting to like, you know,
shut the anti-vaxxer is up, you know,
prevent them from speaking.
But that doesn't win, right?
That that's not a victory.
What we need to do is persuade them.
Why do you believe, think this? So,
so if you compare college
students to adults,
some evidence suggests they're
not more sanctimonious.
Some evidence suggests
there are some polls, uh,
if you look a disadvantage there
clearly rising, but they're still small.
So, so the critics say there's
a rising level of [inaudible],
which I deplore let me just, can I go on
a degression? Yeah. Yes. So I have no,
let me be very clear because there's
a lot of sloppy thinking about this.
Nobody has a right to
speak on a college campus.
So I'm not claiming that
anyone has the right.
But once a group on campus
invites you to speak,
you cannot yield to the
mob Verdis invitation.
It totally destroys the university.
It's,
it's the antithesis of what
a university should be like.
So you can protest that person,
but you cannot have dissertations.
That's just ridiculous. So, so
they're, so those have been rising,
but so the critics say, look,
this invitation had been rising,
but the defendant saying yes, but millions
of Tok state place and nobody objects.
So it's a tiny minority. So to
answer your question, I don't,
I don't think we're beyond the hump,
but I'm not the expert to tell you.
How bad is it?
Does it say something about the
state of liberalism or in a way that,
that this was sort of the end conclusion
of liberalism? I hate to say it,
that it would get sort of usurped
by progressivism or whatever the new
collectivist idea was. In other
words, liberals are tolerant.
Liberals generally are live and let live.
So it was sort of fertile ground for
people with bad ideas to Russian and kind
of take over where perhaps conservatives
are a little harder to get in at
they derivatives. Yeah.
Yeah. But conservatives have
their own political failings.
Right. But I have no doubt. Yeah.
They'll move in lock step so you
can get them to like, you know,
you two to mark to get, to get to
organize an inquisition. Right. So,
you know, it's not like, right.
We can conserve. I'm Larry,
I'm not comparing either one.
I'm just saying that there
is a weakness of liberalism,
which is very sad for me to say. The
openness is exactly what invites, yeah.
So this is the radicalism within. So I
mean I think this is, I mean I think,
you know, the open society and
its, and its enemies. Um, you know,
I think there is a sense
in which you can use the,
the tools to destroy the foundation.
Um,
but I also think,
and this is one of the arguments that I
made and I actually believe politically,
which is that these very core
commitments to freedom of assembly,
freedom of expression,
which the students were using right now.
Then we're also engaging in harassment,
which is a different topic.
And because I was an actor
in those events, I was,
I didn't feel at liberty to
help the students see the
difference between freedom
of expression and harassment.
Right?
Yeah. Somehow I don't think
they would've been like, oh,
let's sit down and listen to him as you
explains why, you know, so you can, so the
classic example is the, you know, is that,
you know, you can, you can march
through the streets of Skokie, Illinois,
but you can't stop in front
of my house, right. Because,
you know, that is a threat,
uh, the political expression
and a public places not so, so,
uh, so the students, so the, so,
uh, um, I lost my train of thought.
Where was I going? Uh, well, basically the
idea that the liberalism and that, yeah.
So, so the, so the,
so, so these are chord,
that sort of non-corrupt judiciary
sort of impartial separation of powers,
freedom of assembly,
freedom of speech.
I regard these as like foundational
principles of our democracy,
which are essential liberal principles.
Liberal principles. Yes, yes.
Liberal Bristles, which the students
in some ways we're using, right. Um,
except to call for people to be fired
for expressing their ideas in a collared
campus is using these
principles but to liberal ends.
And this is what you're asking,
I think,
which is what you're saying is can
these tools be used to like degrade the,
and the answer is yes,
there is a kind of threat from within,
but I still wouldn't abandon the
principles and I don't want to abandon the
peanut goes either. Okay. There we go.
You want to shift to the book or you want
to keep going? No, no, no. Please, please,
please. I would much rather
talk about this book. All right.
So it's called blueprint, the
evolutionary origins of a good society.
So let's start with the tag there.
So we actually live in a good society.
I can't believe it.
I thought we live in the worst society.
Capitalism is evil and the patriarchy
and so many terrible things,
and we've done horrible things, but
say this is good. Yeah, I'm appalled.
Can you please explain this about
commercial statement? Yes. Okay.
So I think there has been a long tradition
in the sciences and in the public
domain as well of um,
focusing on the bad side of human nature,
on our propensity for tribalism or
selfishness or violence or hatred.
But equally we are natural selection of
our evolution has equipped us and shaped
us for love and friendship and cooperation
and teaching and all these other
wonderful qualities.
And in fact,
I would argue that these good qualities
and their benefits must necessarily have
outweighed the bad qualities and their
costs. Because if I came near you,
I'm now speaking over evolutionary time,
over tens or hundreds
of thousands of years.
If I came near you and you killed me or
filled me with lies or otherwise injured
me, I would be better off
living separately. So, so the,
so the fact that we live socially
suggests that on balance,
the benefits of a connected
life must outweigh the costs.
So the books, the book,
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
push back at these claims that we are,
that humans are inexorably evil.
And these arguments I should make,
I should say, are
supplementary to the, uh,
the body of ideas that Steven pinker
and others had been advancing about the
sweep of history. So where Stephen
is interested in historical forces,
I'm interested in the
books over there. So, yeah,
an Amy's I see in a bunch of
other younger Steve and Amy. Oh,
my friends Neil Neil crew by data.
So you want to be yes,
please put me over there with those guys.
Yes, exactly. Some of those guys. Yes.
And Schirmer's book. I can see. Yeah,
these are great. Um, okay, so, uh,
uh, yeah, the moral arc.
[inaudible] great. So I'll make
sure you have a copy. Okay.
But anyway. Um, so, so, um, so, uh,
uh, so Steven is arguing
that, uh, you know,
basically since the enlightenment,
the philosophical principles
in the scientific discoveries,
discoveries of the enlightenment,
the world has been getting better and
he's unquestionably bright. We are safer,
less violent, healthier, live, longer,
wealthier, better off at every,
every possible dimension. And that is
largely a product of historical forces.
But what I'm arguing and
technological forces,
but what I'm arguing is that we don't
just have to look to our history to find
this goodness.
We can look to our pre history and
actually over tens of thousands of years
we've been shaped to be good.
We have been shaped to be able to live
together in productive ways, in good ways,
actually in morally good
ways. I even argue. So, so the
both works synergistically,
these two forces and in,
and in fact,
I would even argue that these historical
and technological forces are actually
just a thin veneer on top of
much more powerful forces.
So he's there a bizarre
evolutionary force that,
that inclines us to focus on the negative.
Oh no,
that's a good question. I suspect if I had
to get one per show, no, no, no, no, no.
Um,
I would say right because if you
a person or things good or bad,
people generally tend to bed. We watch
the local news. That is all terrible news.
We're conditioned sort of. So there must
be something that's leading to that. Yes.
I think that, I think, I
know this has been studied.
I'm trying to quickly call
the literature to my mind. Um,
if I had to speculate on what the
conclusions of that literature would be,
it would be that there's more advantage
to paying attention to bad news and good
news that, that the fitness
advantage is survival advantage.
The advantage to your wellbeing from,
um,
noting a fire in your vicinity
or a Predator or a killer,
uh, is more advantageous to you than,
than, uh, than noted the noting the on,
on average the presence of water
or a food or a kindly person.
So I think, I think that that's probably
why we're hardwired to be pessimistic,
but actually we're not,
let me be clear. So, uh,
so we have both pessimistic and
optimistic, uh, inclinations. People.
And of course there's Inter individual
variation. People vary in this,
these personality traits.
But I think on overall we are
definitely inclined to the good.
So when you described yourself
as an optimist before,
if you had to try to parse that out
between what you think human nature is
versus upbringing and everything else,
could you give it some percentages?
I mean where your parents optimists so
that then push a well as ideas to you or
I think it's important not to
conflate personality traits. Uh,
which I am a optimist.
I think it person by personality with um,
sort of,
um,
how to put this exactly the kind
of characteristics of our species.
So I think we, for example,
we are cooperative species.
We cooperate with strangers,
which is very unusual.
Other animals will cooperate with,
but we also cooperate with non-kin.
It's rare in the animal kingdom. So I
don't know how you would describe that.
I wouldn't call that optimism exactly.
I would call that something
good cooperativity.
That's a characteristic of our species.
And then above and beyond that
we also have personalities.
Some of us are optimistic, some of us
are not. But all of us, for example,
love our mates. So here's an interesting
idea. Why? Why do we do that?
It other animals have sex with each other.
We're not the only animals that do this,
but we also love each other.
We formed sentimental attachments to
the people we are having sex with.
We are also tend to be monogamous
and that we can be by monogamous,
I don't mean social monogamy
or even heterosexual monogamy.
I mean we form a longterm attachment
to the person we're having sex with.
Whether it's polygynous, polyandrous,
straight or gay, doesn't matter.
We love the person we're with. Why?
Why do we evolve this capacity? Well,
I talk a little bit about that. Why
would do that? And it's universal.
Everywhere in the world you go,
no matter what the marital system,
people love their partners instantly.
We get too proud of ourselves. Birds.
90% of bird species are also monogamous.
But anyway,
so the point is is that there are all
these qualities we have or we befriend
each other. Why do we do that? We, we
don't just reproduce with each other.
We form longterm non reproductive unions
with other members of our species.
Namely, we have friends. This is very
rare in the animal kingdom. We do it,
certain primates do it, whales, orcas
and dolphins do it. And elephants do it.
Why? Well, there's a reason we do it and
it's a wonderful quality of our species.
So do you think societies
should be organized to help
these institutions? I mean,
this is where I could throw out Jordan
Peterson's enforced monogamy and you know,
people had a field day with that at all.
He really was saying was that societies
should kind of look at marriages,
it Justin thing,
because it's a foundational thing
that will help you build a family,
help you build it for full of life.
Do you agree that that's part of what
would lead to a good society or which
should be instilled? Well, I say
I talk about that in the book. Uh,
when I talk about is that we should be
very wary of efforts to engineer society
in opposition to our evolved proclivities.
So societies that try for example,
to prevent loving attachments.
I talk about communes for example,
communes have a problem because in a
commune they want you to feel loyalty to
the group,
to the commune.
So therefore feeling of love
for your partner is a threat.
So many communes have gone
two opposite extremes,
both of which are attempting
to solve the same problem.
So on the one hand you have the shakers
who say no sex, no loving attachment.
On the other hand you have
communes that say polyamory.
Everyone loves everybody or
can have sex with everyone.
Both of those are attempting to sever an
individualistic connection between two
people,
which therefore you in the same thing
happens in eastern Germany where they
tried to separate connections
with friends, right?
You don't you who my friends could be
spying on me or ratting out to the Staci
[inaudible] sitting there for a second.
Cause it's a fascinating idea
that it's the same force at work.
Whether you say to people
don't have any relationships,
is actually the same divorce as have
relations with everybody. I mean that's,
that's not something that the
average person is thinking about.
But if you're just having
relations with everybody, yes,
you're actually having on special
nobody. That's right. So they're both,
both of those extreme strategies
are tackling the same problem,
which is the threat to the collectivity
of individual relationships,
whether it's with your partner,
your sexual partner,
or as I was about to say
with your friends or others.
So collectivist societies will often,
every everyone call you comrade.
So everyone is your friend.
Same as having polyamory, right?
It's like the polyamorous equivalent
to everyone dresses the same.
We all call each other friend. No
individual identity. It's a kind of,
it's a kind of science fiction dystopia
actually. So the argument I make is,
is that we should be very wary of efforts
to engineer society in opposition to
our interests.
They're bound to fail is my argument.
Now there are brief moments of time and
certain cultures where you can apply a
tremendous cultural force and suppress
some of these innate tendencies. So,
for example,
I talk about the not,
so if you look at societies around
the world that the, the, the,
the expression of love for your partners,
seeing universally,
except perhaps with one exception,
which is the not people in the Himalayas
who've organized society around a brief
sexual encounters,
you're not supposed to love your partner.
And so this is a matrilineal society.
The women stay at home.
The men will go out at night basically
cruising for dates. So there'll be like,
and it's not uncommon for every woman
to have had sex with every man in the
village. And the men will be knocking
on the door, take me tonight, take me.
And she'll pick this guy tonight
and they'll have a brief fling.
Maybe he can come back and at any moment,
either of them can break off the
relationship, but even in it,
and so there's a whole
complex cultural edifice.
Marco Polo describes this
when he gets to China,
the Chinese government thought
it was sapping productivity,
that everyone was having sex all the
time. They were, they were saying,
we need to stop this. They tried to stamp
it out, but it still has existed. This,
this culture, this cultural set of
rules. But even in this society,
there are people who want the
forbidden fruit of having a,
a committed relationship and who flee
for because they want to be with each
other,
forsaking all others.
So even this society cannot fully
suppressed this desire for love.
And I look also at friendship and
show that there are some societies,
very few which seem to have no,
um,
experience of this notion of friendship.
But those societies are extremely rare
and also have certain idiosyncrasies.
So the simple way of saying that'd be
that there's basically an evolutionary
force that no matter how far you go to
one extreme, it has to sort of push you.
Yes. Or that it's extremely difficult
to entirely suppressed. You can,
through force of arms, you know, you can
slaughter populations. You can, you can,
you know, you can, uh, you can,
um, have very elaborate, uh,
sort of autocratic governments.
You,
you can have procedures or other highly
evolved stylized that have cotton to
this.
For example,
there's a play is universal and
children and there's one society,
the [inaudible] people who really think
play is awful and really try to suppress
the innate tendency of children to play.
So there's very little play among
children in that society, but it's,
these societies are rare and they require
very large cultural forces to suppress
these innate tendencies.
You know, I was thinking as
we've been talking about this,
that there's something
also sort of related to our
political situation right now
about this that it seems like we're
sort of going off the deep end.
I would say the argue more on
the left at the moment. Um,
but I guess if I'm an optimist here
and I described myself as a world weary
optimist that you're saying at some point
and whether Jonathan Haidt says it's
two years down the road or whenever it
is that at some point we'll eventually
have to rebound right. Secrets.
Sure. Cause it, what is it?
If it doesn't rebound
then, then that's just, no,
I don't think Jordan Peterson
would say is just chaos. Right?
Yeah. I think, I think, I mean, I, I
can't, I think we're in for another,
I think there'll be
about five or 10 years.
Our society is going to go through
a long period of, of, of acrimony.
Um, no, I have to say I'm
not, you know, um, sort of,
I don't have a wig ish view of history.
Like, oh, in the olden days, you know, uh,
everything was great. I mean, let's
not forget we had, we had colonialism,
we had slavery,
we had a,
we had to anti immigrant sentiment
forever and our couldn't even vote. Yes.
Women couldn't vote. Exactly. Do
you have gay rights? You know, so,
so there's always been this uh,
this incredible disconnect between our
wonderful principles in our society.
All men are created equal.
You know,
the bill of rights can bring
tears to your eyes if you read it.
And the fact that we didn't always,
but we are, I think getting better.
This is the progressive in
me. You know, the society,
we're getting better and better.
We are expanding the franchise
to more and more people.
We are opening up our democracy.
We are, we are extending rights,
we are extending liberties. Um,
now of course the libertarian,
we'll say the government
doesn't grant liberties.
We are protecting liberties are,
you know,
we are trying to stay out but took
it right out of it is exactly.
And I agree with that actually.
I don't think the liberties over the
governments to grant, but anyway, so,
uh, but I think our society is
getting better in these regards. Um,
I don't think you can, you could
say otherwise. So I think that we,
we will get there.
It's just going to take some time.
So how do you navigate through
a messy time like this?
If you're someone that's just kind of
awake to these ideas and you want to be
able to express your individuality,
but there is a mob or a morphous
machine that is silencing things,
or as you just said before,
that you don't want a society that's going
to push down things that were sort of
always accepted for a long time.
I'm slightly paraphrasing, but,
so right now it's like if you call a man
a man, they'll tell you you're a folk.
These, these basic things that seem,
now we hear about them constantly as if,
as if this is just the most
important thing happening.
No,
I think
there are other,
this is the other thing.
I think that I think there are certain
segments of Twitter in certain segments
of our society that have made these
particular topics than others.
A very central in everyone. You
know, the people who want to,
who are concerned about climate
change or people who come as I am,
they're people who are concerned about
the private Prentice prison industry as I
am. These are two hot
topics at Harvard right now.
So there was a heckler situation
where the president of Harvard was,
was not allowed to speak about,
he was at an educational conference
and these groups that were opposed to
private ownership of prisons, which I am
and, uh, concern about climate change,
which I also am, they shut the president
down, which is ridiculous, you know?
I mean, why did they shut him?
Because he thought he wasn't taking,
paying enough attention to their concern.
So you,
you have this kind of ruled by minorities,
right?
Where a vocal minority can hijack the
conversation about whatever particular
topic they have. So everyone's entitled
to have their topics of interest.
But that doesn't mean you have
to go along with it, right?
You can have your own ideas
about the topic or you can
switch conversation. Like,
I'm not interested in talking
about trans rights today.
Today I'd like to talk about, uh, how, uh,
motor vehicle accidents are the one of
the leading killers or the opioid crisis.
There's another important dilemma. Where
are the guns? You know, we, we, we have,
we have more people are killed by guns
in our society per capita than any
society in the world almost.
It's craziness. So, um,
so all of these are different
people have different, anyway,
the point I'm making is that if you
wish to engage in a conversation with
someone about a topic
they feel strongly about,
I think it's incumbent on you
to listen to their arguments,
think and then respond.
So do you think there's an evolutionary
reason that people either basically
become sort of government
people or freedom people?
So the way you were laying out
that argument, is that going to go,
it's like you were telling me your
progressive, uh, sort of prayed,
which I have to do all the time,
but then you basically said, yeah,
but all these things can be accomplished
by libertarianism if you don't believe
that it's the government's
job to give these things.
So that basically it sort of shows why
the progressive's are the ones screaming
on campus all the time.
And it's in larger society because they
think the system can be perfected to get
it however they want it.
Where are the Libertarians?
I think just say I'm very wearable system.
Yeah.
I don't think the system can be perfect.
So let's just keep it out of our lives.
I mean, I think, you know, which,
which idea I'm more sympathetic to.
But do you think there's a reason
that what occurs? That yes.
Okay. So there are, there are
a set of ideas about where do,
where do so,
so the content of political beliefs,
like whether for example you believe
in, um, whatever it is, pick I know any,
the,
the belief you have about a particular
topic is of course not evolutionarily
shaped,
but there is a kind of evolutionary
shaping to whether or not you are more
conservative or liberal. That's
what I'm trying to get. Yeah.
So some people are more rule abiding and
there's an, there's a good, for example,
children that learn children that listen
to their parents might be more likely
to survive. So listening to your parents
is actually a good survival strategy.
On the other hand,
too much obedience is also bad.
You can be led like a lemming off a cliff.
So occasionally you need to not
listen to what everyone else is doing.
So both are advantageous and we're,
we're equipped with both abilities and
there's variation across people and it's
a complicated topic.
So nobody thinks there's like a genetic
background to being a Democrat or a
Republican.
But there is evidence that there is a
kind of genetic predisposition to certain
political polls.
But what I would say though is
that we live in a plural democracy.
So you're going to have to
compromise, you know, uh,
if you're a libertarian
who thinks x, Y, and Z,
and you're going to be in a society with
other people who think different things,
we have decided to come together as a
people and vote to resolve our disputes.
And t by the way,
not just to vote,
but to educate ourselves and to teach
each other stuff, right? To communicate.
Right. The founders recognize
that in order for us to
get to the wisest decision,
we have to have free and open
conversation. Well, I think that's why,
which I support I do here.
Well of course you do.
But that's why so many people are so
concerned about this at the college layer.
You know, I'll hear some of
our critics will say, oh,
they're just obsessed with
what's happening on colleges
and they're handing over
all this power to the, to
the mob oncologist. But then,
but then every day we
see it then leak out.
And also these people will
be the leaders of tomorrow.
That's why I don't think it's,
I don't think it's overestimating.
And even if it is a small minority,
which we agree,
the amount of power they can extend,
they definitely needs to be way
disproportionate to the numbers. For sure.
I would agree with that.
Uh,
I would agree that the vast majority of
students on any college campus just want
to get a good education and,
um,
and many of them have other political
concerns other than some of the ones that
are getting a lot of attention. So, um,
you know, even for example, even with the,
you know, so you know, people are
concerned about the opioid crisis.
They're concerned about gun violence,
are concerned about police brutality.
They're concerned about
the climate change,
are concerned about all of these issues,
which I think weren't concerned.
We can perfect our society, we can be
better than we are. And I generally,
we can perfect it. I, I do better than we
are. But you think we can perfect it. No,
I don't think we can
have a perfect society,
but I think we can make it better than
it is. So by perfect, I mean improve. Um,
so I think we can make our
society better and better.
I don't think we're done yet. I think
there's still deficits are, for example,
our spending is crazy. I mean, I think we
do better fiscal fiscally. Um, you know,
I think we have, we have a
carceral state. We have, I think,
I think this number's right,
that upper on a per capita basis.
We have as many people in prisons as
Stalinist Russia. I mean, it's insane.
You know,
we have millions of Americans are in
prison and it's way out of proportion to
other countries. Um, you know, there
are lots of things about our society.
We have very high,
we have century long heights of
income inequality in our society.
There's a big debate about whether that
is an unavoidable side effect of growth.
You know,
everyone is better off.
So what do we care if the
income is unequally distributed?
But I think I tend to be agree with the
critics that are concerned that this
level of inequalities not sustainable
to have a common wheel to like have a,
a sense that everyone is
a part of the society.
We've had no income growth in the middle.
Uh,
like the meeting American has seen in a
generation and see no growth in wages.
Right? So the bottom actually has raised
and we've watched the top go bananas,
but the middle of the bottom hasn't even
gone up that much either. Well, let me,
let me put it this way. They
have absolutely not been
living standards, right?
So like a poor American today is vastly
better off than a poor American a
generation ago. But in terms of wage
growth, there's been very little growth.
My understanding of statistics and most
of the accumulation of wealth in the
last generation has gone to
the top, top 1% 0.1%. Anyway,
there's a debate about why that happened.
The technological advance that we have.
The same thing during the
industrial revolution. These
are important deep ideas,
which as a society we should
be debating and discussing.
What's the best for our society anyway,
there are,
these are all much more
important topics in my view,
and have much more bearing on the
wellbeing of our society than a lot of the
other crap that gets so much attention.
So what's the evolutionary
reason for that? I mean,
your previous book was about social media,
right?
So there's gotta be some link there.
I mean,
and it's already getting
back to what I was saying.
I know I've got depressing local
news. I don't know. I mean,
I'm trying to talk about things
that I think are important.
Um, you know, I, I, um,
I'm doing my part as best I can,
who's done a society in a more quote
unquote good way than we have right now.
So, uh, so the book, so I don't, I don't,
I'm not, it's not a work of history,
so I'm not, I'm not, I don't
primarily talk about, um,
like the last 200 or even 2000 years
of human evolution or experience.
I'm much more interested in the long
arc of our history. And if you look at,
um, forged your societies around
the world as I do, and you,
and you look at their qualities,
you will see that again and again.
These societies have these
desirable properties. They,
there's variation of course,
and how cooperative they are.
And there's variation in marital systems
and there's variation in sustenance
systems. There's a lot of variation.
But also there's a lot of commonality.
And those common features I argue are
universal. See, here's the other argument.
The argument is that,
uh,
there are these universal qualities
that are shared across all societies.
They are shaped by our evolution.
They're not just a product
of historical forces.
Can you just list out a couple
of them again, just so, so
love, love a friendship,
uh,
cooperation where cooperative species,
you'll be kind to a stranger
on the first tee. You know, uh,
teaching the fact that we
teach each other stuff,
which actually is the ultimate source
of all our wealth and wellbeing.
The fact that we can accumulate knowledge
and distributed across time and place.
So I can tell people far away something.
And when I'm born,
I benefit from all the other knowledge
that has been produced for the many
hundreds of thousands of years
before me is astonishing.
And I would again argue this is why
what's happening on college. Yes,
I would argue with, I would agree
with that. There's a connection there.
Like our capacity to teach and to
create environments in which we foster
teaching and learning are crucial anyway.
Also hierarchy.
We are a species that we cannot
survive with no hierarchy.
We need some leaders and I discussed
that but we also don't like too much
hierarchy.
So when you get too autocratic power,
the little guys down below band
together and basically kills.
So Richard Wrangham has been making this
argument that we self domesticated as a
species that over millennia bands of
weaker members would say, you know,
that guy's too powerful and he's getting
all the dates and this we're going to
kill them. And basically they did. So
we got more peaceful as time went by.
Is One of the ideas,
mild hierarchy in group bias.
So some tribalism is
unavoidable in human beings. Um,
this capacity for identity that
we discussed at the beginning.
These are all qualities. So identity,
love, friendships, social networks,
mild hierarchy in group bias,
teaching and social learning.
These are seen everywhere and they lie
and I believe at the core of a good
society and, and institutions, uh, uh,
try to suppress those at their own
peril. Yeah. How can you be sort of,
have a healthy dose of in group preference
without starting to fall into the
trap of identity politics. So for
example, you're agree guys. Yes.
Greek thing I did. I love Greek, my best
child friends growing up in the Greek,
we're still great friends.
Um,
I love Greek culture and the way that
opened a Greek and the interest in
intellectual wisdom and I love feta
cheese and all of those things.
Span of Kopi dialogue. Yes. Yes. Great.
So, and you can open a Greek restaurant.
As far as I'm concerned, I wouldn't
object. That'd be totally fine.
[inaudible] I know that port,
that poor girl,
it's insane. It's toe Chinese
residents without being Chinese.
And not just that there was the,
there's the person in in Oregon
that had a Mexican restaurant. Yes.
There's so many examples
of this is unbelievable. So
how can you say love a call?
I just told you all the reasons I
left this year. But let's pretend,
let's say it's roughly the same
feelings about your own culture.
How can you embrace all of those
things without falling into the trap of
identity politics? Because
I think that's, yeah,
so I think there are a lot of
people are at these days. Okay.
So I have a couple of ideas and responses.
The first thing I would say is,
is that that this is one
of the both the most,
it's still not totally clear how
we evolved to have this capacity.
It's felt that this ingroup bias,
this I,
this tribalism that we have was
crucial to our ability to cooperate.
That the ability to draw a distinction
between us and them, that the challenge,
the problem that, that this
ability that we evolved. So,
so there's whether we cooperate with each
other and whether we are xenophobic or
tribalistic or draw distinctions
between us and them. And this property,
this tribalism property is a property
that reduces the scale of interactions.
So instead of you having to
cooperate with everybody,
you only cooperate with your guys.
And this is innate in human beings and
it is felt that this ability to draw
distinction between us and
them was crucial in the
emergence of the variability
to cooperate with other
people. Okay. So they're tied,
they're connected to each other.
What's is,
is it necessary to hate the other group?
Why can't you just love your own group,
right?
So why could you be indifferent to the
other group or even admire and say that
to them?
They're not us.
We like them or we are in different to
them. Why do we have to kill them? Right?
Like why, you know, where does
the killing part come from? Right?
And this is complicated.
We don't exactly know like where
the hostility comes in weather,
but we tend to see this hostility.
So for example,
are famous experiments that have
been done with little toddlers.
You can randomly assign toddlers
to different tee shirts.
You can test at the toddlers
understand that this was random,
that there was no merit to whether they
got the yellow t shirt or the green t
shirt. And yet as soon as you give
them the t shirts, the yellow t shirt,
kids say those green t shirt children,
they shouldn't have toys.
They're bad children. They don't
deserve, you know, anything. It's insane.
Look like you can see this is called
the minimal group experiments.
So the most trivial of interventions
you can elicit in us this, this, this,
dislike of the other.
However,
this is not the only tool that
evolution has given us to live together,
this disability to draw the
boundary between us and them. Uh,
there are a couple of other tools and
before I tell you what those two other
tools are, let me just say one other
thing. So if you think of our society is,
here's our whole society and here's
our groups in the middle and here,
individuals at the bottom. If you're
struggling with the problem of tribalism,
there are basically two ways you can go.
You can go up a level and broadened
the boundary and you can say,
for example, we are all
Americans, right? You can say,
because we all have the
capacity to draw the boundary,
we are evolved to have that capacity.
Now you just say,
actually these little group boundaries
that we were paying attention to,
they're not,
they're not relevant and basically take
all the ethnic divisions or other than
the religious or immigrant or whatever
it is, and we're all American.
We're all American. This other group,
yes, at a higher level. Exactly.
So you move up a level and you efface
tribalism by appeal to larger groups.
This has been part of our history
since the beginning to talk.
They'll talks about this
where nature of joiners,
you know anyone can be an American,
that that itself is part of the
American project. It's astonishing.
The belief which I share that anyone can
be an American is a statement that the
groups don't matter.
Anyone can be an American,
you just have to buy
our liberal principles.
And then you could be an American even
though there's a debate about that.
But there's also an interesting parable
to Trump here because at some level it's
like he's talking about
a miracle all the time.
So that is the higher
group for all of this.
And yet I suspect your feelings
on what he's doing. Yes.
There's some other things, probably
not, no, but I would be like,
anyone can be an American.
If you come to our country and
you work and are productive and,
and obey our laws and our constitution,
you're an American as
far as I'm concerned.
It didn't matter whether you
came from Mexico or you know,
one of the four Mexican countries
as he's, you know, anyway, okay,
so a whole other show. Okay, good. So,
so, okay, so, so, but another solution,
okay to the group is of the
tribalism. Mr. Go down a level.
Remember we talked
earlier about individuals.
So now you can say instead of looking
at people as which groups are they a
member of,
you look at them as individual people.
And this too has been
a part of our history.
So Martin Luther King's
famous sentiment, I, you know,
I'm look forward to a society in which
people are judged by the content of their
character rather than the color of their
skin isn't appeal to our individuality.
Seen groups don't matter.
Individuals matter. So,
so if we're struggling with tribalism,
we'd go up or we can go down both help,
however lateral to that point,
there's another set of ideas,
which is tribalism is not even the only
tool we have in order to reduce the
sense of scale and to cooperate.
So natural selection is also
equipped us with friendship,
friendship,
the really one of the reasons it is felt,
we evolved the capacity for friendship
is again to reduce the sense of scale.
So instead of now and
being in a big group,
everyone has to cooperate with everyone.
Each of us has a subset of people who
are our friends that we cooperate with.
So it's similar to tribalism,
but different because now
instead of defining it by group,
membership is defined by each
person has their particular friends.
So this is another tool that we innately
have that we can use to sustain our
cooperative instincts and
push aside the tribalism.
So how much do you think on a day, day
and a day to day basis, are we, uh,
normally I get the water for people.
You had to be so wrapped up there.
That's what I forgot. Uh,
on a day to day basis,
how much movement do we as
individuals have to sort of
either go around,
let's say go around our
evolutionary behavior?
Well, I don't think, okay. So I think
I do believe in free will. I mean,
I think you have,
um,
some capacity to self mastery and make
her own decisions in life and your own,
you know,
um,
but you're also born with certain innate
qualities and you're also born a human
being, which is you're part
of a particular species
that has a particular set of
characteristics. Um, so I,
I think that as individuals, you know,
we have some control over how we act.
I don't think our individual actions will
individually change the whole society.
But I think if each of us is
attempting to do the right thing,
I think ultimately that
makes things better. Look,
there's a lot of famous ideas.
Uh, so a Victor Frankl who was
in the concentration camps, his,
his wife was killed.
He survives the Nazi concentration camps
and he goes and he writes a famous book
called Man's search for meaning after
he's liberated it right to 10 days after
his liberation.
And he talks about how he came to the
recognition that even in this camp in the
most vile possible circumstance where
his life was threatened every day,
where people were dying all the time. He
was starving to death. He had no shoes.
It was in the winter.
I mean it was a slave even
there he recognized that he
was the master of his own
internal state.
You know,
that how he saw the world was
something that was in his own control.
So he was able to find a sense of
self discipline and mastery even in an
environment in which the structures
around him were engineered to crush him,
to kill him. So, so I think that there
are, and there are many examples of this,
I mean another one of my favorite examples
is a Buddhist monks that were studied
at MIT years ago. I think I'm going
to get the facts of this work correct.
So,
so,
so they were very interested in how
meditation changes the structure of your
brain and how are these monks so able to
be so peaceful in these very stressful
circumstances.
And they scan them,
they put them in the MRI scanner and
they looked at different parts of their
brain in which parts were enhanced or
diminished compared to other more ordinary
mortals. And uh, and then,
and they saw the different parts of the
brain and Buddhist monks were different
than the rest of us.
But what interested me was not even the
neuroanatomical discoveries that were in
that paper,
but it was the interviews with amongst
and so at amongst would say was that,
for example,
let's say you and I are in traffic and
someone cuts us off a normal response,
certainly one that I often have
is who is that jerk? You know,
you'd be really pissed off and your
blood pressure would rise and maybe you'd
race that guy and uh, you know, you
would, you would think ill of them.
That would be our natural goto thing.
That's a thoughtless,
maybe they're idiotic or
they're inattentive or you
would have all these bad
thoughts about this person who, you
know, in a road rage kind of way.
The monks don't do that with, amongst do
is they train themselves to regenerate.
So when that happens,
so then they say,
maybe that's a man who's taking his
wife to the hospital because she's
delivering the baby. The baby's
being born in the car in front of me.
Isn't that amazing?
There's a new life,
I should help that man to get to the mean
and they're doing it not for the sake
of that person, but for their
own wellbeing. You see, so,
so I think it's possible to, to, to,
to re, even though it's difficult,
it's very difficult to exercise
some internal self control.
I think you're mostly saying that there
are no monks on Twitter. Yes, very few.
The Dalai Lama,
my things on Twitter,
I think I follow up on do I think
I have to check. He's on Facebook,
I'm pretty sure.
What else do you think sort of the average
person that's watching this can do to
help order a good society?
Because I think people, you know,
everything's become so political.
Yes.
I think people think that's the only
solution to sort of help make a better,
I think granting charity to your
enemies I think is important.
I think listening to them,
cultivating, listening, you know, um,
that's pretty big of you to
say after everything. Well,
I was listening in the clip you showed,
I was listening.
I thought that was so ridiculous.
The young woman who said,
I'm not listening to her.
I was really listening.
I mean I was listening then
and before and after. Um,
I don't agree with what she was saying,
but I heard what she was saying.
I could summarize what
she was saying but even,
but what do you do in that case
then? It just sort of, yeah,
we don't have to bring it back to that
specific instance, but in general,
because I think a lot of
people are going through this.
You're being berated by somebody.
They're saying all the worst
things about you and your motives.
They're attacking you as a person.
All of those things now you can listen,
you can absorb and ignore.
You can ignore.
All Ruth Bader Ginsburg says survival
in life is ignoring a lot of the
stupidities,
which I also think is good.
I think that's the answer and what was
ignore and also who was that famous
actress that found this guy in Texas
that had said horrible things to her and
then, or him I can't
remember, was an actor,
an actress and it was an actress
and made it her business.
To find out about this guy's life. And
he had lost his health insurance and he,
and then she intervened and raised
money for his healthcare and, and,
and he felt seen and heard,
wow, I can't, which one?
It's an incredible story.
And um,
and I think that a lot of times people,
and I think anonymity is a real,
it can contributes to bad behavior online.
So I think sort of as Jordan
Peterson says, you know,
man up as it were a woman up and have
the strength of your convictions.
This is what I think, this
is what I'm going to say.
But is there a problem there?
I mean,
Jordan,
I've done this many times where then
depending on how that hierarchal structure
is operated, if you are saying
something that's an politically correct,
well,
I mean you have to have the strength or
revise your opinions or stick to them or
make good arguments but are listening.
But you know, let's don't engage.
Let's say you're a Trump supporter.
You just don't want to lose your job
because you think if you say that
[inaudible] I'm against
people losing their jobs for
their opinions. Yeah. So, uh,
so you know,
so I think that,
I think there's a thing where I
think a little bit of bravery,
a little bit of civil discourse,
a little bit of commitment to
granting charity to our opponents. Um,
a little bit of like for example,
when I would have an argument with
people who are opposed to vaccination,
I think there is no merit to their ideas.
I understand their fierce.
I understand that there have been either
some actual cases of vaccine induced
neurological conditions, one in a
hundred thousand one and 500,000 cases,
which is awful.
And I understand that there are a lot
of coincidences where people think that
there's a relationship, but no,
it's just that you have, you know,
you have lot of vaccines
are being administered,
there are a lot of illnesses occurring.
There's going to be an overlap
in those two sets. But,
and I also know the data
on how that's very been,
how vaccination is like
a 20 20th and 25th,
actually more like even a 19th century
triumph. I mean, you know, we've,
we've mastered these diseases.
We humans,
it's astonishing what we've done through
our capacity to teach and learn and
engage in science and so forth. But I
would engage that person. I would try it,
I would talk to them. I would
say, you know, let me talk
to you about your beliefs.
And because I think that that's the only
way to get them to revise their beliefs.
I think telling them they're fools
doesn't, doesn't help. Yeah. Um,
so a true liberal, I am a liberal.
Yes I am buying. I am a liberal. Yeah.
But do you think one side is a little,
it's a little bit easier to do that
right now. And does that flip over time?
So for example, right now I find
it much easier to go to consider.
I get invited by conservative cliffs.
Libertarians is no problem.
But let's say conservatives that I
have disagreements on, on abortion,
gay marriage,
and legalizing marijuana.
And the death penalty. And we could
do the list cause I, oh wait, hold on.
So I'm for legalization of marijuana. Yes.
What is your position on death penalty?
I'm against the death. Let
me too. What were the other
gay marriage? Yes. Yeah. Uh,
legalizing weed. Um, so, but
yes, sorry, I hate to tell you,
I'm guessing that you
only would get invited by
conservative groups to basically
to college as well. I don't know. Um,
I don't know. I don't get that many.
I mean usually my invitations are
scientific. Like I am a scientist.
Like I give talks about my science.
So I have not historically been
very politically but, right. So,
but what I'm getting, I really is that at
the moment it seems very obvious to me.
Like I don't know that I could be clearer
or anything on the center right there
is,
there is a,
an ability and actually a
desire to discuss ideas.
I would agree to disagree and that
just isn't happening right now.
And I would suspect her argue, and I'm
sure you can give me examples where that,
I mean during the McCarthyism
for example, I think, you know,
it was very difficult to be a
communist for sure and even, you know,
left where they were so they weren't
inviting communist talk to them.
That's right.
So I think, um, I honestly don't
know the answer to that question.
I think there are subgroups on campus
which are still committed to debate the
get the political unions. These guys
love to argue these young people. Um,
I think there are other vocal minorities
on campus that don't want to hear
opinions that they don't agree with and
they think that even the hearing of it,
there's this, there's this very sloppy
conflation of speech with violence,
which I think is ridiculous, um, which
seems to really be ramping up. Yes,
I would agree with that. And you also see
it, for instance, in Pakistan, they will,
they will kill apostates that's
answering speech with violence.
If you actually think that
someone believing in a
different God and expressing
that belief is violence, then then the
country justifies killing that person.
Or in Brunei recently, they had the same
kind of um, situation. I think this,
this is, I strongly reject that
belief. There's, there's uh,
we have different words and there's a
totally different meeting between speech
and violence. So, uh, so I don't know
how we got onto that topic, but uh,
oh, so, so I think that,
I think there are groups
of people on campus who do
conflate speech and violence.
I think that's a problem. Um, but there
are also many groups that are very,
very vigorous political debates.
I think one thing that is different,
so I'm in my fifties when I was
in college in my, in the eighties,
we would stay up late and argue
about politics with our friends,
with our friend's notice.
I said my friends,
I would argue with my friends about
politics and a, and they were my friends.
I don't think that
happens very much anymore.
It does in the political unions
and the debates societies.
But in the broader college,
I think if you have a different opinion
about abortion, for example, um,
you really can't express that.
But
the weird thing is that it is happening
with conservatives. Well cause they,
because they do believe, I mean I go to
these things and I have these debates,
we have kids all over,
all of their better debaters cause
they have more experience. Yes.
Arguing with people they disagree with.
Yes.
They get a better education in some ways
because they have to constantly defend
their opinions. It's a weird thing to
say then. Yes, yes, yes. I think, well,
I mean if you, this is the thing
why in the martial arts for example,
why don't we bow to our opponent?
You'll learn more from the people you
disagree with and from the people you
agree with. Right. In Jay's
mill's famous saying, you know,
he who knows only his side of the
case knows little of it. Um, so,
you know,
I think,
I think that's where your ideas
get better when they are tested.
Um, when you argue with
someone you disagree with, um,
and, and, and I think,
and I think cultivating
those kinds of conversations,
disciplining yourself to be able to have
arguments with people you disagree with,
uh, improves your ideas. And actually
you should be grateful to that person.
There's more interesting
person in some ways. Um,
now you don't have to be best
friends with that person necessarily,
although you can be. Um, but
I think it makes you smarter
that my friend is a nice closing statement
and you've lived through it. I mean,
that's the point. You lived through the
forces that so many of us see now as,
as such dangerous forces in society
and now they live through it.
You flourished and you've got another book
out and all of those things. So, well,
I would say, I mean, yeah, well I
would close with saying, you know,
I really believe that, um, that
the arc of our evolution as long,
but it bends towards goodness.
Sounds good to me.
You guys can follow nick on Twitter at
Naa Christakis and we'll have a link to
his book.
Write down below.